while some moviegoers might argue that
the perfect scene doesn't exist quite a
few Marvel movies come darn close to
proving that argument wrong buckle up
because we're diving headfirst into the
most memorable iconic and practically
flawless scenes in the MCU Ironman is a
masterpiece of a movie Robert Downey jr.
x' performances Tony Stark is exactly
what the MCU needed to gain some
momentum right out of the gate while
it's a great experience from one end to
the other though there's one scene that
stands out above the rest we're talking
about Starks emergence from captivity
decked out in the towering first version
of his Iron Man suit the mark 1 the
clunky armor is a rough start compared
to the nanotech that Stark eventually
creates it gets stuck in the wall and
requires a handmade spark to launch its
missiles and it's not exactly durable
but it's all he needs to blow that
popsicle stand and then hightail it out
of there leaving the astonished
survivors of the 10 rings in the
rearview mirror the death of unasyn adds
some emotional fuel to the fire - as he
implores Stark not to waste his life
don't realize the emergence of the MC
use first bona fide superhero was pulled
off with a precision that simultaneously
cut to the quick and had us on our feet
cheering sometimes it's an unspoken
understanding between characters that
makes a scene truly flawless few action
movie moments have done this as well as
Steve Rogers reckless sacrifice at
training camp when he throws himself on
a grenade that he doesn't know is a
dummy this moment in Captain America the
First Avenger punctuates a debate
between Colonel Chester Phillips and dr.
Abraham Erskine about who should be
recruited as the first super soldier in
their program
Phillips casually tosses the grenade
into the midst of the new recruits at
which point everyone scrambles the one
exception Rogers the scene is a splendid
illustration of Rogers ideals all
wrapped into a single action compare
that to the moment in endgame when he
faces down Thanos his entire army or the
numerous occasions in which he professed
that he could quote do this all day that
guy started as a skinny fella with a
heart of gold ready to jump on a grenade
if that's what was required even a super
heroic transformation decades spent
frozen in ice and cosmic confrontations
with unimaginable evil couldn't take
that away from him everything hits the
fan when Thanos arrives on the scene in
Avengers infinity war while endgame
would eventually even the score by
dusting the mad Titan and seeing the
good guys back on top its predecessor
marks one of the first times Marvel
actually ended things on a sour note and
we mean a really sour note
the story comes to a fever pitch as
Thanos plucks the mine stone out of
visions forehead completing his gauntlet
and then snaps his fingers after Thor
fails to finish him off the sequence
that follows takes us across the
universe showing the effects of the snap
is half of all life in existence
crumbles to ashes on the spot one moment
on Titan is particularly emotional as
spider-man bids a desperate farewell to
his mentor Tony Stark
back on earth Steve Rogers slow
realization that they have just lost is
just as moving as he sits slumped on the
ground in defeat with his friends turn
to dust around him while it may not be
fun the decimation is one of the most
flawlessly executed moments in the
entire and see you
directors Joe and Anthony Russo have
brought us many of the MCS most
compelling moments and their work makes
it onto this list more than once a
particular highlight though is the
Captain America Civil Wars climactic
confrontation the final moments of the
film see Steve Rogers and Bucky Barnes
face off against a furious Tony Stark
who has just discovered that it was none
other than a brainwashed Barnes himself
who killed his parents the scene is set
against a cold hard backdrop of snow and
stone as the heroes tangled through an
abandoned Cold War facility in Siberia
Stark's superior armor seems to put him
at an advantage but it's ultimately
Rogers attitude that helps him defeat
the iron Avenger by putting a shield
through his arc reactor from stellar
cinematography to the wrenching
emotional conflict to the choreography
of the fight itself everything about
this scene is a home run
Michael Rooker's yondu udonta steals the
show for a lot of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 however the scene in which
he stages a jailbreak and then retakes
his entire ship with the help of rocket
and baby Groot is particularly priceless
the scene cheekily set to the needle
drop of J and the Americans come a
little bit closer perfectly embodies the
spirit of the Guardians franchise
irreverent careless mindlessly violent
unpredictable self-destructive and
downright hilarious the sequence shows
yondu's arrow speed around the ship
hunting his mutinous crew one by one
until he finally takes out taser face
and the entire ship to boot the
legendary feet firmly establishes yondu
as a Mary puffins tear hero y'all and
just in time for him to make the
sacrifice play as the film wraps up the
scene is deliciously tongue-in-cheek and
masterfully leaves the audience
struggling with a brand of morbid humor
that only James Gunn can so casually
invoke
you maniac the airport fight scene in
Captain America Civil War is incredible
on so many levels though they fought
one-on-one plenty of times this is the
one and only occasion that the MC use
heroes have taken each other on as teams
and it's positively dripping with
quality action beats naturally the
fighting is preceded by some light
banter because even at their lowest
points Marvel's heroes can't contain
their sarcasm once the joking is
finished though the divided group gets
down to business and boys it fun to
watch our diversion
nice job kid nice the scene has Tom
Hollands spider-man swinging into action
for the first time even nabbing caps
shield while he's at it
Scarlet Witch continues to showcase her
impressive power set as well and
newcomer to chala cuts a dashing figure
in his vibranium black panther suit even
ant-man makes a huge splash by
transforming into giant man and wrecking
everything in his path the thrilling
moments just keep coming with this one
from start to finish the airport fight
is one of the most exciting and funniest
action sequences that the MCU has ever
produced I'm really sorry I've done that
earlier I hate you Thor's character has
come a long way since those early phase
1 days while his second solo outing Thor
the dark world is not exactly a fan
favorite the god of thunder story had
new life breathed into it with thor
ragnarok in this wild adventure the hero
finds himself stranded and enslaved on
the garbage planet of Sekar this
ultimately leads to his being forced to
dawn armor and enter a gladiatorial
arena to face the grandmasters champion
who turns out to be none other than Hulk
the entire scene in the arena is
perfectly executed from Thor's each
other the friends who are lying to the
movies nod to everybody's favorite scene
from Avengers
[Applause]
to Thor and Hulk raucous brawl that ends
with the so-called Lord of thunder
electrifying the Jay giant before being
incapacitated by his obedience disk the
scene also serves as a sweet shout-out
to Hulk's own Planet Hulk story from the
comics all while kicking off his own
three-part story arc of self-discovery
within the MCU the first Avengers movie
follows Earth's Mightiest Heroes as they
get together for the first time iron out
their differences and stop a Chitauri
invasion of New York City led by Thor's
trickster brother Loki with so many
great scenes unfolding throughout the
film though there's one that has to be
called out every time the shot of the
six heroes suited up together in the
ruin streets of the Big Apple with a
portal open above the city and the fate
of the world at stake the team finally
gets their act together just in time for
one of Steve Rogers first great moments
as a leader of the Avengers with Tony
Stark's blessing cap takes charge
assigning roles to each hero and helping
contain the unfolding disaster long
enough for the iron avenger to fly an
inbound missile through the wormhole to
wrap things up at Hulk smash but it all
starts with that one shot circling
around the six heroes as they stand
back-to-back ready to fight and die
doing their duty Marvel had been
building to that exact moment for four
straight years and it serves as a
perfect crescendo the MCU has a lot of
last-minute arrivals and nick of time
heroic entrances that make you want to
get up out of your chair and start
cheering at the top of your lungs but
there's one scene in particular that has
to make it onto the shortlist of greats
Thor's arrival in Wakanda in Avengers
infinity war after spending the bulk of
the movie off on his own side quest in
search of a new weapon the god of
thunders arrival on the battle swept
plains of Wakanda is literally
electrifying it breathes new life into
his allies and utterly terrifies his
enemies those that don't get blown to
smithereens within the first few seconds
at least is added war cry of
[Music]
sends shivers down the spine as he
charges into the fray with Stormbreaker
in hand the entire event is an
optimistic beat in a movie that
generally grows ever Bleeker from the
beginning onward and the thrilling
change of pace is inserted into the
narrative at the perfect moment
sometimes the best scenes come in the
form of unexpected sidebars between
characters in thor ragnarok the tensions
are high when thor is thrown into the
grandmasters prison after arriving on
Sekar he knows that he must face a
champion and still somehow find a way to
stop his sister hella and yet with so
much at stake the narrative pauses to
introduce two new lovable characters Org
and meek fellow gladiators who quickly
bond with the Asgardian made of rocks as
you can see but don't get that
intimidate you you don't need to be
afraid
unless you're made of scissors see just
a little rock-paper-scissor joke for you
upon their first meeting Thor arrives in
the freaky circle Corrigan forms the god
of thunder about his newfound captivity
fills him in on the numerous details
about himself and his friend meek and
even goes off on a tangent about a
failed revolution that he tried to start
up oh well I tried to start a revolution
but didn't print enough pamphlets so
hardly anyone turned up except for my
mum and her boyfriend who I hate the
impressive thing about the scene is how
seamlessly it's woven into the greater
story casually introducing two
light-hearted characters who end up
having a massive impact on Thor's
destiny Winter Soldier gradually turns
up the tension as Captain America begins
to realize the full extent to which
Shield has been infiltrated by Hydra it
all comes to a head during a long
elevator ride the slow tension of the
scene ramps up beautifully as cap stands
hands crossed while more and more
bruisers step onto the lift filling it
up to maximum capacity his line before
we get started
does anyone want to get out is the
perfect kickoff to a fight of
claustrophobic Li epic proportions
within moments Rogers takes on the
entire elevator carpeting the floor with
his opponents knocked out bodies
the final line quote it kind of feels
personal followed by the kick can catch
of a shield as pure gravy for a scene
that leaves no doubt that Steve Rogers
is a guy you don't want to mess with he
may be soft and warm on the outside but
backed into a corner or an elevator the
guy simply can't be brought down
I could do this all day check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]